es hat die zwei sind so alles kommt
zurück ich komme zurück ich habe nicht
aufgegeben ich stehe offen reden und man
sieht das cover ist ja auch als bild von
dir wie du sehr ernst kock und dann
reißt es auf und du lächelst dieses
lächeln ist wieder so es kommen wieder
gute tage wie der deutsche aus sagt
schon nach nach dem regen kombination
ist und auch in der phase von dem album
habe stellt auch ein bisschen familiäre
probleme gehabt so wo ich mich natürlich
so auf gestärkt habe mein vater hat
einen herzinfarkt da muss ich auch
zuhören vater gibt es war wieder so ein
stoppball aber ich dachte es wird wieder
und so wie alles kommt die guten tage
kommen auch wieder und ich werde nicht
aufgegeben ich komme wieder zurück und
ich werde den leuten zeigen dass ich
auch alleine kann ohne leute auf die ich
mich verlassen habe weil wie soll ich
sagen ich habe damals zum beispiel
hatten stoffel diese welt verlassen
blind verträge unterschrieben wo ich
heute mit diesen verträgen zum anwalt
gehen und extra noch mal 1000 euro
bezahlen damit der für mich durch
schließt ob alles ok ist ob ich das
unterschreiben damals habe ich mir
scheint auch freunde verlassen und habe
einfach blind unterschrieben wo heute
die securitys von den leuten kommt dies
um die sache zu klären und nicht er
selber und die mir sagen nicht mal ein
idiot wird diesen vertrag unterschreiben
diese kritik die auf ihn aufpassen die
zu mir sagen sie dort damals seine 2006
seine erste million gemacht denkst du
erdreich ernst genommen weiß wenn man so
eine sache von dritte von zweiten
drittpersonen hört weißt du dann tut es
schon ein richtig lese dann denken und
so wie fertig du meine zeit meine zeit
drei stände für loyalität und liebe
geschenke für leute die ich echt mit
herz und seele auf der straße auch
versucht habe zu beschützen ich habe ich
steche kassiert für diese leute und am
ende haben hat meine mutter mein vater
haben geweint und heute sogar sehen dass
ich noch dran also daran wenn du dass
ich kämpfen muss dass das alles so läuft
soweit ich wusste in dieser schiene
bleiben ich wusste da wirklich noch
durch diese tür durch weil wie gesagt
mein stolz hat das nicht mitgemacht
irgendwo in deutschland
wo zu arbeiten ich habe es angefangen
und ich musste da wirklich noch das tun
was ich verdient aber ich will nicht das
was alle unbedingt haben ich muss kein
ferrari vor der tür haben ich muss keine
gekaufte wohnung haben
ich will einfach nur das was ich
verdiene wie jeder andere das kriegen
soll was er verdient wollte ich einfach
nur das aus was verdienen
da habe ich mich echt noch so
zusammengerissen dank meinem manager ich
sage ganz ehrlich er ist auch ein freund
von der straße hat mir wirklich viel
geholfen und das sind leute denen ich
auch wirklich so wirklich dankbar dass
sie mich wieder so auf die beinen geholt
haben und das stoppt die kraft habe so
etwas durchzumachen wenn sein vater oder
der mutter noch so krank ist am sterben
liegt dass ich noch die kraft habe das
durch zu machen
da merkt man sich das leben ist hart das
leben ist echt gemein und ich wünsche
niemandem so eine art das leben ich
hoffe jeder das was er will ok hier in
deutschland nehmen wir alles schön und
gut es gibt viel schlimmeres und anderen
ländern die sonst so was respektiere
aber jesus jetzt für dich bist du noch
oder ist das etwas 1 1 eine seite seiner
persönlichkeit die dich immer wieder
einholt oder ist es etwas das sie schon
hinter den gelassen hat eigentlich habe
ich hinter mir gelassen
aber es ist natürlich heute noch sachen
offen die ich noch von damals noch noch
ausgleichen muss ich habe zwei drei
jahre lang ich konnte meine miete nicht
bezahlen
das war auch eine harte zeit für mich
während die anderen mit denen ich war im
internet rom positiv ihr geld zu machen
und einem auftritt mit irgendwelchen djs
die gar nicht mal da waren bei ihm weißt
du
und das sind so sachen die eine mögliche
tun und die leute denken immer denke gut
der wahrnehmen er hat ihn ausgenutzt
jetzt macht er sein eigenes ding
das ist nicht so dass versuchen ein
album zu erklären das sind so sachen die
ich schon damals noch wie gesagt konnte
23 jahre lang möglich keine rechnung
bezahlt nicht war selbstständig
angemeldet dass ich muss jeden monat
1500 euro sind damit seine miete zahlen
kann damit meine versicherung bezahlen
auf meinen teil bezahlen kann
und das war nicht der fall bei mir und
wie willst du das machen von monat zu
monat es kommt nix kommt nix von links
wo du hast keine auftritte gar nix
und es staut sich alles auf und
irgendwann ist mir bis hier hin und du
denkst natürlich wie soll ich das alles
schaffen was soll ich machen soll ich
meinen kopf halten
nein das geht auch nicht das ist nur
schwäche du warst ja vor
ich habe echt sowas gedacht möglich ich
habe schon sowas gedacht wirklich aber
ich bin froh dass zeit ein bisschen
überwunden hat und jetzt mehr dran bin
somit herzlich seele
es läuft jetzt alles läuft